[Music]
hi mystery recapped here today i'm going
to explain a horror sci-fi film called
as the gods will
spoilers ahead watch out and take care
at the beginning of the movie three
students shun amaya and ichika are shown
as a voice in the background complains
to god about his dull and boring life
in the next scene we see shun along with
his friends in the college classroom
where a doll named daruma doll has
forced the students to play a game
the game is daruma-san garonda where an
ugly looking daruma doll with only a
head is seen on the desk in front of the
students the doll turns around after he
sings and if he finds someone moving he
kills them and turns them into red
marbles
remember this came out before squid game
the remaining students start worrying as
they are unaware of the game rules and
might end up joining their dead friends
one by one their number starts
decreasing two of the boys try to open
the door to escape but find it locked
they are caught moving by the doll and
killed immediately suddenly a gamer boy
approaches everyone to read the message
at the back of the doll the message says
that the game will be over if they press
the button a guy quickly runs to press
the button but the doll turns around and
kills him suddenly shun notices that
there's a timer on the back of the doll
and realizes that they don't have much
time left hearing this several other
students run to switch it off but every
single one of them fails at last only
shun and the gamer boy remain as all
other students are turned into red
marbles making it impossible for them to
reach the doll without slipping with
time running out the gamer comes up with
an idea and tells shun to use his back
to jump over the dead bodies to press
the button easily shun finally presses
the button thus ending the game as the
survivors are celebrating the doll
declares shun the only winner and kills
the gamer the movie then cuts to the
past when life was boring and normal for
sean he is sitting on a couch playing
video games and changing channels after
the game ends at school he is walking
with his gamer friend who suggests he
asks ichika out as she passes a smile to
him ichika is another student in the
school who also loves to play video
games shaun answers that he does not
have any feelings for her and sees her
only as a friend both of them head
towards the classroom when they meet a
boy being beaten up by amaya the school
bully inside the classroom shun falls
asleep and a loud sound wakes him up
just then his teacher's head explodes
and the daruma doll appears the events
at the start of the movie continue from
here in the present shun starts praying
to god to return him to his boring life
the daruma doll calls shana a mouse and
tells him that a cat is coming for him
very soon meanwhile ichika akimoto
approaches shun's classroom and is
horrified after seeing its condition
shaun asks her if she knows what's
happening but she says that she's as
confused as he is they try to call the
police but find no signal they then try
to flee the school but all the exits and
doors are locked the duo then run from
the scene towards the basketball court
where they are surprised to see some
students in mice costumes who survived
the daruma doll they look at the floor
and find the words fit the cat's bell
for it to end the school president then
orders them to wear the mice costumes
just then the floor of the court opens
up and a gigantic plastic cat appears
from beneath the big cat starts gobbling
the students one by one which sends
everyone into a state of panic shun
notices the ball-like bell with a timer
on it he quickly informs everyone that
in order to end the game the bell must
be passed through the basket placed on
the cat's neck one of the students who
is a good basketball player shoots the
bell but the cat manages to catch it and
throws it back at the student killing
him instantly shun seems to be a genius
and quickly notices that the cat is
killing only those who are wearing the
mice costume he then suggests everyone
remove the costume to which everyone
complies for a while the cat remains
idle but as the student starts
celebrating the cat devours another one
the students start screaming and running
again and ichika falls on the floor
amidst the chaos shawn immediately gets
into the mouse costume and starts to
distract the cat he realizes that by
wearing the costume one can hear the
voice of the cat all this time the poor
cat was just requesting them to scratch
its back so that it could sleep quietly
that's just like a cat using violence to
ask for pats shun quickly gets on its
back and starts scratching it he then
tells the others to join him and the cat
finally falls asleep now that the cat is
asleep shun grabs the bell and proceeds
to throw it over the hoop the other
students however stop him as they think
only the one who scores the bell will be
the winner ultimately they all start
quarreling with each other as they are
fighting the cat wakes up and starts
attacking the students again shun comes
up with a plan once again he takes
ichika inside and conceals the bell in a
regular basketball to deceive the cat as
they throw the ball and are ready to
celebrate the bell bounces on the ring
but suddenly amaya arrives in the nick
of time and heroically scores the shot
thus ending the game the cat then
declares that only shun ichika and amaya
can live sean asks about the fate of the
losers but before he gets an answer
amaya kills the remaining students amaya
then says that only the strongest will
survive which is god's will amaya
approaches shan and tells him that both
of them are alike as they have what it
takes to survive ichika on the other
hand disagrees and says that shun is
kinder stronger and smarter than amaya
on hearing this amaya is infuriated and
tries to attack her but the cat sprays a
gas from its mouth and knocks them all
out in the next scene a news channel is
seen reporting about the incidents
happening around the schools as a
terrorist attack another news report
shows large cubes hovering above the
cities and mentions the defense and the
police departments are yet to find any
entrance into the cube despite various
attempts the media also reveals that the
survivors of the incident are god's
children as they are able to survive
such a tough situation
some media and interviewers along with
the professor from a university are seen
mentioning the incident as the alien
invasion of human existence next we see
a homeless person repairing a damaged
radio just by touching it later shun
wakes up in one of the cubes among the
other survivors he finds takumi his
childhood friend along with a shy and
timid girl tiara and an arrogant but
intelligent student tayoka shun is
disappointed to be finding himself
playing the death game again he tries to
escape but finds all the doors locked
tayoka then informs him that the only
way to escape the room is by winning he
also brags that his intelligence will
lead him to victory through a screen
they are informed that they have to find
the keys to escape just then four wooden
dolls enter the room they introduce
themselves and the rules of the game
they say that each of the participants
will be blindfolded and the dolls will
circle them singing songs when the song
stops the participant will have to guess
which of the four floating kokeshi
wooden dolls is behind them within 10
seconds failing to guess correctly would
result in their death however if the
kokeshi dolls lose one of them will
explode releasing an answer key that
will open the doors and allow the
survivors to go to the next level the
confident tayoka goes first and tiara
second both of them fail to answer and
are ultimately killed the dolls then
approach takumi next but shun insists on
going first with the help of his
intelligence he wins the game as he was
able to note the difference in their
voices with the help of his phone he
then reveals that he had recorded their
voices when tiara was playing after the
game ends the dolls explode leaving
behind a key which shun grabs he then
leaves the room along with takumi
outside they see a guy being chased by
an ugly looking doll the guy approaches
them and asks them to hold his hand to
save his life he mentions that the dolls
can't hurt those holding hands they
decide to help him out and the doll
leaves saying that he is jealous of
those whose friendship is strong shun
looks at the pendant takumi is wearing
and goes into a flashback
there takumi is ready to commit suicide
from a rooftop when she notices shun
smashing cups and glasses onto a wall to
release his anger shun then offers
takumi to do the same and she starts
breaking the crockery which makes her
feel better at present she is wearing
the same cup handle that shun had
offered her suddenly they hear a girl's
voice screaming from the other side they
run towards the screen and find ichika
running away from the same dreadful doll
shun jumps to hold her hand immediately
and saves her soon after a wall erodes
and reveals a doll's face with seven of
the key entries shun and his group reach
the place where two contestants are
already waiting they count their keys
but find that three of them are still
missing suddenly amaya appears at the
scene with the remaining keys and kills
his companion as only seven of them are
able to qualify for the next round when
all of the seven locks are unlocked the
doll face announces them as the winners
and it erodes backward into the wall
making a passage-like structure then a
voice directs them to follow the passage
by wearing the costumes provided here it
is revealed that all the games are
telecasted all over the country next the
group finds themselves inside a frozen
room a large polar bear enters and
introduces himself he mentions that he
hates liars and black-hearted people in
the game the contestants just have to do
one thing speak the truth failing to do
so will result in their death the game
begins when he asks everyone about their
favorite food after they reply the bear
suspects someone of lying the bear gives
the participants two minutes to present
the liar at first they defend their
answers but later all point towards the
guy who answered parsley the bear then
instantly stomps him to death well
that's what happens when your favorite
food is parsley for the second question
the bear asks if they like shun all of
them who know sean including takumi
answer yes and the others who don't know
him answer no the bear still believes
that one of them is lying to him and
again suggests the remaining
participant's name the liar all of the
participants answered to kumi as the
liar as shun and takumi were out of
contact for a long time despite shun's
best attempts to save takumi she gets
killed devastated by the loss of his
friend shun screams that the liar and
traitor among them is none other than
the white bear himself it turns out to
be true and the bear sheds his white
color and reveals his original color to
be black as all the lies are caught the
game officially ends and the survivors
are taken to the last game the remaining
five participants are taken to a temple
after the door opens three wooden dolls
welcome them and also congratulate them
for making it this far the three of the
dolls introduce themselves as fitness
intelligence and imagination they reveal
the last game name as kick the can for
it to end one of the participants will
be the demon and the rest will be the
victims until the demon places the can
on the designated place the victims will
get their time to hide the demon will
then have to find all the victims he
will have to name them after seeing
their faces after which he can imprison
them inside the cells in this way if he
imprisons them all and kicks the can he
will be the winner however if a victim
manages to kick the can the other
victims will be considered the winner
and the demon will lose but the victim
who kicks the can will die as the can
explodes
then the five take turns picking sticks
with the red stick going to the demon
amaya obtains the red stick he quickly
places the can on the ground and starts
searching for the others two of the
students are quickly captured ichika
then sacrifices herself in order to
distract amaya while shun escapes after
imprisoning ichika amaya screams that he
doesn't need to find shan to win the
game and despite itchika's advice to
hyde shun comes out wearing an armored
suit with which he is hiding his face
shun then tells amaya that it is
impossible for him to get caught as his
face is covered up amaya finds this
ridiculous and he quickly takes off
sean's helmet as amaya proceeds to kick
the can and end the game he realizes
that shun has attached an iron chain to
him shun then jumps into the water and
starts dragging amaya with him as amaya
struggles to pull sean out of the water
he sees that shun has removed the armor
and is slowly proceeding towards the can
suddenly amaya manages to break free and
runs towards the can but shun kicks it
first before him they prepare for the
explosion but nothing happens the game
is finally over and the dolls declare
everyone winners except amaya they also
reveal that the explosion was just a lie
to make the game even more interesting
an enraged amaya then grabs one of the
dolls and says that he isn't supposed to
die as he was chosen by god the dolls
start laughing and reveal that no one
was supposed to die the winners are then
congratulated with fireworks in the sky
the dolls also provide some ice cream to
celebrate their success
while eating the ice cream shun finally
asks ichika for a movie date and also
expresses his feelings for her ichika
happily agrees but when their ice creams
melt they see something written on the
sticks the dolls then reveal that
despite making it this far they need
luck to live amaya and shun notice the
words you live on their sticks while the
other three including ichika find the
words you die a doll then kills the
losers as shun watches in horror while
ichika disappears into thin air
shun and amaya finally emerge from the
cube where they are cheered by a large
crowd they are calling them god's
children amaya rejoices but shun bends
down in despair declaring there is no
god after all of his losses one of the
dolls corrects him saying that god does
exist the movie ends as the same
homeless man from before is revealed to
be god
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching